We now look at an application
of the Bayes rule that's
involves a continuous unknown
random variable, which we try
to estimate based on a
discrete measurement.
Our model will be as follows.
We observe the discrete random
variable K, which is
Bernoulli, so it can take
two values, 1 or 0.
And it takes those values with
probabilities y and 1 minus y,
respectively.
This is our model of K. The
catch is that the value of y
is not known.
And it is modeled as a random
variable by itself.
You can think of a situation
where we are dealing with a
single coin flip.
We observe the outcome
of the coin flip,
but the coin is biased.
The probability of heads is
some unknown number, y.
And we try to infer or say
something about the bias of
the coin on the basis of the
observation that we have made.
So what do we assume
about this y or
the bias of the coin?
If we know nothing about this
random variable, we might as
well model it as a
uniform random
variable on the unit interval.
And the question now is, given
that we made one observation
and the outcome was 1, what
can we say about the
probability distribution of
Y given this particular
information?
So the question that we're
asking is, what we can tell
about the density of Y
given that the value
of 1 has been observed.
The way to approach this problem
is by using a version
of the Bayes rule.
We want to calculate this
quantity for the special case
where k is equal to 1.
So let us calculate the various
pieces on the right
hand side of this equation.
The first piece is the density
of Y. This is the prior
density before we obtain
any measurement.
And since the random variable is
uniform, this is equal to 1
for y in the unit interval.
And of course, it
is 0 otherwise.
The next piece that we need is
the distribution of K given
the value of Y. Well, given Y,
K takes a value of 1, with
probability equal to Y--
so the probability of 1, if
we're told the value of y is
just a y itself.
y is the bias of the coin
that we're dealing with.
The next term that we need
is the denominator.
We will use this formula.
It is the integral of
the density of Y,
which is equal to 1.
And it is equal to 1 only on the
range from 0 to 1, times
this probability that K takes
a value, a certain value.
In this case, we're dealing
with a value of 1, so here
we're going to put
1 instead of k.
And therefore, we're dealing
with this expression here,
which is just y.
And we integrated over y's.
So this is y squared over 2,
evaluated at 0 and 1, which
gives us 1/2.
So this is the unconditional
probability that
K is equal to 1.
If we know nothing about Y, by
symmetry, higher biases are
equally likely as
lower biases.
So we should expect that it's
equally likely to give us a 1
as it is to give us a 0.
Now, we have in our hands all
the pieces that go into this
particular formula.
And we can go ahead with
the final calculation.
So in the numerator, we have 1
times this term, evaluated at
k equal to 1, which
is equal to y.
And then in the denominator,
we have a term that
evaluates to 1/2.
So the final answer is 2y.
Over what range of y's
is this correct?
Only for those y's that
are possible.
So this is for y's in
the unit interval.
If we are to plot this PDF,
it has this shape.
This is a plot of the PDF of Y
given that the random variable
K takes on a value of 1.
Initially, we started with a
uniform for Y. So all values
of Y were equally likely.
But once we observed an outcome
of 1, this tells us
that perhaps Y is on
the higher end
rather than lower end.
So after we obtain our
observation, the random
variable Y has this
distribution, with higher
values being more likely
than lower values.
This example is a prototype of
situations where we want to
estimate a continuous random
variable based on discrete
measurements.
Essentially it is the same as
trying to estimate the bias of
a coin based on a single
measurement of the
result of a coin flip.
As you can imagine, there are
generalizations in which we
observe multiple coin flips.
And this is an example
that we will see
later on in this class.